let's talk about msnbc let's keep it
going to fake news we got this from
newsbusters another story insane msnbc
host thinks desantis wants to codify
white supremacy by banning critical race
theory msnbc is known for its insane and
vile commentary which occurs on almost
daily basis but this one might be the
craziest comments this week during a
segment on msnbc's the beat with ari
melber filling host jason johnson
discussed governor ron desantis his
support of a bill that would ban
critical race there in public schools
johnson claimed the proposed legislation
titled stop woke act is desantis's new
effort to codify white supremacy for
political gain what does white supremacy
mean see this was one of the the big
issues that occurred one of one of the
points of contention for the episode we
did with uh with r.a the rugged man was
that
i don't think even he knows his own
definition of white supremacy and a lot
of people don't
typically the cultural right believes
white supremacy too mean someone who
believes they are genetically superior
based on their race or the ideology of
that
but the leftists critical race theorists
believe white supremacy literally just
means dominant culture
so when the left says white supremacy
they're referring to the fact that most
people in this country are white that's
it so they'll say things like
uh when they say you know hollywood is
is a white supremacist institution
what people on the right here is that
they're accusing people in hollywood of
of believing they're genetically
superior based on race what the left is
saying is that it's a it's an
institution created by white people that
mostly benefits the majority uh the the
largest you know race like majority race
in the country
because of this you end up with stories
like this they make no sense
so when
so so i would argue this
if you take away the word white
supremacy and replace it for what
they're actually saying and say that um
jason johnson said the stop woke act is
desantis's new effort to codify
traditional american culture for
political gain it's like oh
yeah maybe
i mean sure i don't know it doesn't
sound nearly as insane well i think
definitions matter here and that's why
in yesterday's interview i was like wait
what do you mean by this what is your
understanding of this because i think
there was a disconnect with what we
thought the words mean and when it comes
to the word white supremacy it has been
used and abused to such a silly level
that i feel like in some instances it's
losing its its meaning it's losing its
power because it it rained and msnbc was
freaking out saying it's white supremacy
that caused it to terrain uh i'm being
fascists here but but they literally
almost blame everything underneath the
sun if you're going on nature hikes
that's white supremacy native going out
of nature is white supremacy and i'm
like
uh you're devaluing this word in this
meaning so for msnbc to say this as
hyperbolic as they are it's like okay
okay what are you really trying to say
here because you bastardized the
language they're zombies
they're zombies zombies and zombie lords
that was i love that conversation we had
when ian was here i was like because npc
zombies kind of interchangeable and then
i mentioned well some of these people
know they're lying but i think the
people at msnbc who are saying this
stuff are just mindlessly repeating the
words but there are people who know
they're changing the definition of the
words to manipulate people into
joining their cult ideology and so i
asked are zombies evil and i think ian
first said no he's like no no you know
they're neutral or whatever and then and
then we looked up or actually no i think
he said zombies are evil in the in the
official dungeon of dragon zombies are
evil so even if you are mindless like
this is the perfect example of the
banality of evil mindlessly going going
along with evil i'm sorry that makes you
evil you know what i mean yeah luke
you're totally right the definition
changing and then they repeat the words
that are not they're not they don't mean
anything anymore i'm calling this the
death of language that's how you create
multiple realities because there's a
whole group of people operating in
certain definitions and there's another
group keeping
operating in different definitions like
the the when the guy drove the car
through the people the christmas parade
and we saw a lot of tweets and headlines
that was a car that drove through the
suv
you're killing language there right it
was an accident
but if it was someone else who looked
differently they would sensationalize
that to make it very specific to make it
you know you afraid of that it's almost
as if it's orwellian it's almost as
we're going through double speak
which i i've heard of that yeah yeah
yeah yeah and i think that's
we could relate to that since of course
even scientific definitions of herd
immunity vaccines are being changed
right in front of our eyes when it meant
something else previously before and i
think the same thing is happening with
white supremacy uh racist change that
went from being just prejudiced against
somebody because of their race to being
about powers and systems and oppression
and prejudice and white people
are or black people can't be racist and
white people are only they can only just
have prejudice against the very elbows
black face of white supremacy yeah i
mean it just it has no meaning it's
watered down and then but it's like
crazy that these audiences either love
that they're changing the definition or
don't realize it but either way it's the
same end result and it's evil there's
there's a couple a couple of the issues
you know uh and i and i gotta say like
we all really want to talk about what
happened last night but it really was a
good example of the culture war
and and what happens afterwards so one
of the things that happened afterwards
is vosh we've had myself a couple times
he's um he's made progress
i i i have great respect when he first
came on the show he called me far right
yesterday or i be or maybe earlier today
he called me a conservative so he's
moving me closer to the middle
almost i'm getting close to being a
centrist
but he actually defended me
he actually he made a really good point
he said
he said something like let's be real
guys
if this was any other mixed race person
explaining they experienced racism and a
white person was laughing in their face
and insulting them you would be on that
person's side but because it's tim poole
you want to be mad at him and i was like
wow and then vosh wanted to say temple
is a conservative and then of course
that means he's racist and i was like
come on come on so close you're so close
and then i go and then and then he plays
he presses play and i go i want to
abolish the police and he goes thank you
tim and i'm like bro
the problem is everybody shared one
small clip so the the narrative becomes
something untethered to reality if any
one of these people would just actually
take their heads out of the sand and
consume media
to better understand it then a lot of
this might stop happening but the other
issue is
when it came to the actual conversation
with with uh you know r.a
many of these people
don't agree that he is being racist
because in their new moral framework or
lack thereof
white people are allowed to insult
people who are not white
and that's not racism so long as their
ideology is in line with the tribe or
the cult
so when they say racist what they're
really saying is deviant they're they're
saying you're a deviant you're a deviant
so when i call him a deviant people go
no he's not he's perfectly in line with
wokeness so to them they're hearing me
basically like they don't hear the word
racist the way we do when when i say to
him you're a racist i'm saying you
literally said that you would judge
someone based on the content you judge
someone on the color of their skin to me
you're being racist when you
discriminate against someone on their
race to them racist just means you are a
deviant from our from our ideology if
you were a media darling and he was and
ari was in here with a maga hat and he
accused you of laughter you they would
have said tim poole you know asian asian
podcaster you know to make sure oh yeah
we all knew he's a victim let me let me
explain something that you know one of
the jokes that we make on the show every
so often is that blonde hair blue-eyed
luke rydkowski is a person of color and
literal second generation mixed-race
temple is white
i'm like i don't even know what is going
on in their brains
like but but i think it's fair to say
what they're really saying is deviant
when they say racist or white
supremacist
you brought up this point would would
you happen to have the old definition
and the new definition by any chance
because i think i saw something online i
don't know where to look racism of the
term racism um
not that i mean not the exact definition
but off the top my head i believe it was
something more along the lines of what
we generally believe that it's just hate
or prejudice because of somebody's race
or skin color now
i think at least one dictionary and just
in many schools of thought like in
academia you'll see the definition be
changed to it's uh it's like it's it's
prejudice and prejudice plus power so
black people can't be racist because
they could be prejudiced but they don't
have power in today's white supremacist
racist system so black people therefore
can't be racist and white people can't
be victims of racism because they have
the power and the prejudice so they just
nothing nothing just comes at them and
then luke isn't white because slavic
people experience oppression
and asian people in america are white
because they have high incomes on
average
so
they've turned white into an ideology
it's a boogeyman well if you look at
history history is filled with
oppression whether you're you're chinese
or japanese or korean or polish um you
look you know people have been screwed
over throughout historically but you
know do you see people leveraging that
for their own kind of purposes or
excuses is to me it's it's it's it's
like thinking low of somebody and and
it's thinking low of yourself and i
think some of it is done deliberately
this is just my perspective i might be
wrong someone might be might be able to
convince me that i'm wrong but but for
me i think something that really does
oppress people is saying continually
you're oppressed you're oppressed you're
oppressed and when you keep putting that
into someone's mind
they create an identity that is
oppressed that does believe that they
have lack of opportunities and that kind
of
mindset that kind of idea that kind of
larger consciousness that you're putting
out there to your regular life that
you're manifesting that you're creating
is creating that of of of lack of of
being the victim i want to chase this
deviant idea too because there was some
something else that came up yesterday in
the show that exemplifies this
when i was trying to explain a very that
you know this world is comprised of many
people with different world views ra's
response was i said your world view he
said yeah reality
and so
when he so here's what i think happens
he believes
he's in the moral majority he believes
that his ideas are represented by most
people or that you know he's on the side
of good or whatever
but a lot of these people don't seem to
realize that when you have you know 80
million people voting one way and 80
million people voting the other
certainly there are two distinct you
know perceptions or i should say
overarching perceptions so for me when i
started getting into into this work and
i mean just doing journalism in general
i remember um i went out during occupy
wall street there was a pro-life rally
at the federal building by wall street
by the by the stock exchange and we went
and we saw these people and we saw them
waving their flags and i listened to
what they said and my attitude's always
been like
if we're talking about helping the
working class that means recognizing
that half the working class are
conservative and half are you know left
or whatever and that means we really
need to understand where people are in
general not just one side of things but
too many of these people think
99 of the country is them and there's
this weird deviant group of people so
when they say you're a racist they're
saying you are not in line with the
moral majority which is us our our our
ideology is correct and then when i try
and point something out like there are
80 million people who who roll the other
direction from you and don't agree with
you they just they say that's not true
they don't believe it they reject that
or they say well those people are wrong
and crazy or grifters or liars and it's
like
that's why you'll often hear people say
that the right things the left is
misguided but the left thinks the right
is evil i think it's starting to change
now with many on the right many and and
the funny thing too is the right is not
just right wing it's also comprised of
the center like if you actually look at
pew's research on this which is
hilarious the stressed sideline they
call it a political individuals lean
right
and it's because the left has gone off
the rails when you look at that axios
poll we looked at last week that shows
young democrats are overwhelmingly
antagonistic based on on politics and
not conservatives we can see
whatever is happening it's happening as
an effect of modern left culture or
whatever and i think it's working uh
brilliantly to the benefit of the
special interests that really kind of
pulled the strings that really kind of
set the news stories that set the agenda
that set the narrative because let let's
call a spade a spade here there there's
a lot of things you and r.a agreed on
there's so many things that the
government does you weren't happy but i
know i know but but hold on let me just
get to this point
there's so many things you guys had in
common especially with your visions and
your ideas and your beliefs and things
that you went through that was outside
of the established narrative but on this
point it brought you two guys towards a
very tense angry moment between each
other that's how powerful and divisive a
lot of this stuff is where even if you
could see eye to eye and a lot of stuff
you still fight each other that's crazy
amount of power and division uh-uh i
gotta stop you there bro when r.a says
to me you think you've got it worse than
black people in this country yeah and i
said no i agree with you i actually did
work on the subject and then he says
again three times i'm like bro i don't
know how many times i need to tell you i
agree with you on that
but for him to just be like no one is
allowed to talk about racism because of
the black struggle i'm like this dude
you cannot reason with i i literally
tell him you are correct i agree with
you critical race theory should not be
banned in schools it's just the practice
of it goes okay all right how many times
does he need to say something he goes
y'all called kyle written us a hero and
i said we never did that anyway okay
okay i'm like how many times do i need
to reach out and say i agree with you i
agree with you i agree with you but he
didn't he it's like it's it's not it's
it's that's why i'm saying it's about
being a deviant it's about not being in
line with our orthodoxy so that's what
they're calling you yes
by and large what what i was saying you
said it more eloquently a lot better
than i did because again there were
terms of agreement but it still led to
confrontation which to me is
mind-boggling of of how they are able to
control the narrative in a way where it
still leads to no understanding and a
fighting
and that to me deserves to be pointed
out i but listen
i think we all understood him
i think we were all uh analytical as to
think like
we analyzed the things he had been
saying he talks about news in a way
where he he didn't understand things he
was talking about how we didn't know
what critical race theory was and i and
i gave him just a very generalized
here's one of the authors here's what
they've stated here's what they believe
because i i read this stuff and full
disclosure when we had vosh on the first
time i was i was miserable in in trying
to break down what critical race theory
was and i i think vosh made a great
point when he was like you don't know
what you're talking about and i said
well my view of it is the cultural like
wokeness and stuff but you know what i
absolutely owned up to that and said
it's a good point i should not use a
phrase that i have not read the
literature on so i pulled up the book
from kimberly crenshaw and i started
reading did not read the whole thing i
read it i read the first few bits of it
to understand the origins of it i read
quotes and comments from derek bell i
read some d'angelo and some ebermex
candy and i'm still not going to pretend
to be an expert but for someone to come
in here
say these things and for me to be like
which of these authors do you agree with
and him to be like i don't know that i
have no idea i don't know anything about
it i'm like okay here's a problem if i'm
going to tell you that there's some
there's a lot of the stuff we we agree
on but no matter how much we try to come
to you to your side and say we want to
rectify this you still just say you guys
are racists you guys are white
supremacists you are bootlickers there
is no there is no coming together
there's no compromise there's no
resolving this bridge
i'll just stress this point again when
i'm literally like you're you are right
and i agree with you and the response
from the other side is i don't care
screw you you're a lying piece of crap
i'm just like all right that's it it's
conflict the divide is real and it's
very i'm trying to stay positive
but i was going to ask is there anything
that could bridge this divide is there
anything possible i think so i met a
lady yesterday total stranger in her 70s
a nice lady we agreed on books and music
and we were there looking at some stuff
and there was another gentleman there
who i don't really know but she knew she
pulled me to the side and said he's in
he's an anti-vaxxer and i was like oh i
everyone can do whatever they want i'm
okay and i didn't mind and she kept
trying to get politics out of me and she
was trying to like find labels and how
to like pigeonhole me next right
and then uh 30 minutes later she
says
i wish every republican would drop dead
just like that and she was totally fine
it was normal like she could say it
through a stranger and i'm like what's a
horrible thing to say and i was like i
think i think you are putting labels on
too many people and you you're hearing
certain words like that you know he
didn't want the vaccines now he's all
these things maybe he's racist in your
mind a mega supporter whatever and i'm
like if you just take the labels away
and talk to people about the real
problems you'll probably agree on lots
of things like what tim and ray were
talking about and then she was like you
know i did have an hour-long
conversation with this man he was very
nice but once you said the vaccine thing
all the alarms went off in her head that
she would hear the the buzzwords on cnn
and uh i think if you start to strip
away labels like that's why that when i
see words like woke
i hate words like that i'm so sick of
words like that because it automatically
makes anyone who agrees with woke stuff
um and and who doesn't agree with it
want to fight about it yeah just strip
away the those stupid words i think i
think we use too many bad words like
cancel culture and woke there's a
compulsive need to label people though
people try to do the same thing to me
all the time and even when they find out
what i believe and there's still no
labels to put on it so then they get
even more frustrated but i need to know
i think it's getting worse actually the
compulsive needs to label people but i
need to know like how do we combat that
like how do we change the messaging
toward to the point where people don't
feel the need to be like hey like what
do you believe about that and then
immediately assume your political party
you assume everything else it's like
gang members that's like are you a blood
[ __ ]
luke and i we went to the peace wall in
northern ireland and i really recommend
people go to belfast and look at the
peace wall it
it it it will be a shock to your system
and i mentioned this a lot when i went
there when we were there and there's
like on one side it's pro-israel the
other side is pro-palestine and i was
just i was confused and i asked this guy
who was there i was like i don't
understand like what is what is the the
the irish conflict have to do with
israel and palestine and the dude said
whatever
whatever idea one side adopts the other
side takes the opposite stance yeah it's
just tribalism
and its neighbors living next to each
other with huge walls dividing them
literally neighbors rioting and fighting
each other to the point where they're
killing each other and they're they're
neighbors they live in the same kind of
country they kind of have the same
identity they have a different kind of
religious point of view but that divide
is so strong and crazy where they
literally burn effigies of other
people's um you know belief systems and
and representatives in celebration
in defiance of the other side so that
was a surreal experience to see
um that larger kind of some people call
it a festival that literally leads to
marches and fights and riots in northern
ireland which was absolutely crazy too
and not to see an experience myself
that's just one small area relative to
the rest of the world and this is this
kind of thing is gripping the entire u.s
like you saying the lady said she wished
republicans would all just drop dead
like i gotta i look i think there's a
lot of really great things to focus on
in terms of you know freedom gun rights
are being strengthened but there's also
uh you know i'm not trying to be a a
downer i do think that freedom and
individualism is actually gaining a lot
of ground in a lot of different ways but
i also think the hyperpolarization is
becoming more and more
enraged like like the weight like the
story you as you explained it people are
just getting angry like i don't care
i just hate
and that's scary that's the vic she's a
victim of the corporate press
they fed her fear but it's it's more
than that too i mean so
one of the things that alright said the
beginning of the show is that
he said something the effect of
everything is extremely all these media
outlets are extremely divisive and we're
doing the exact same thing here on the
show and i said you're right i agree
we talk about that when we see msnbc say
that you know ron desantis is codifying
white supremacy or whatever garbage and
then we criticize them and newsbuster
says they're known for insane vile
commentary and all that stuff yeah we're
we're sitting here with a bunch of
people listening and they're going to be
like i don't like msnbc and what they do
and then we're going to get people who
are only to take small clips of this
show and then do the counter of saying
look at what they're saying they're vile
racist or whatever and all it does is
create echo chambers where everyone
hates each other more and more and more
i suppose the one difference is one side
is objectively correct
and that side is whatever this side is
and it's not the right it's not
libertarian it's just literally there
are people who are right and people who
are wrong and if you look at the jesse
smallette story the covington kids
nick's uh nick sandman stuff you look at
kyle rittnow so you look at russiagate
did i say russia look at ukraine gate
two impeachments
wow one side is objectively wrong all
the time what do i get criticism for bad
predictions bad predictions are
different from factual errors if i if i
see the stock market doing really really
well and then say i think donald trump's
going to nail this election and that
covet happens and he doesn't that's just
me not realizing a pandemic was gonna
happen but when you say donald trump
colluded with russia and he literally
did not or you claim these kids were
getting in the face of a native american
and they literally did not you live in a
twisted malformed decayed reality and
then if you become hateful and vile and
angry and or violent because of it yeah
one side is dangerous
and when you have a horde of angry
zombies how do you deal with it that's a
good question is there anything to going
deep in the woods yeah
that's literally what i did i left new
york city went to the middle of the
woods of new hampshire joined the free
state project uh but but is there
anything that could help
and again i made this argument i don't
think we should call them zombies um
because there are people who could go
back from that state from that state of
watching the corporate media to waking
up zombies you can't bring back to life
uh when it comes to corporate media
heads who who watch the the fear-based
mind control people could come back from
that um people could come to an
understanding and say hey i could see
that so i don't think we should call
them zombies because i think that kind
of furthers the divide but but let's
just call them zombies for now is there
anything bringing them back to life and
is there anything that could heal the
divide do you guys
but but i think when i say zombie i'm
referring to the people who are totally
zombified i think there's some people
that you just can't bring back no matter
how you try to reason with them no
matter what type of facts you put in
front of them as was demonstrated i mean
you can agree with something everything
that you're they're saying basically and
they're still going to call you a white
supremacist racist based off of these
new made-up definitions and terms and
they could be they could literally be a
white person sitting here yelling at you
that they could i've had white people
call me i'm anti-black and that i'm
racist and that i hate myself and i have
internalized racism and misogyny and all
those types of stuff and i can sit here
and look at them and laugh at them and
be like and just ask them to explain
themselves and i can't it's just because
like tim said it's just i i like the
word deviant it's just because i'm the
yeah but there is a political
transformation there is a political
change and it happens in in some people
even even tucker carlson carl but it
goes both ways pro-establishment of
course uh pro-establishment pro-war uh
cnn msnbc toting the line giving it you
know repeating the speeches now he
criticizes the republicans criticizes
the democrats criticizes the
intelligence agencies and and does
something with glenn greenwald
yeah
has glenn greenwald on his show and and
um and that's because
and tulsi gabbard on a show all the time
and rages against the the kind of
intelligence state it's a new political
faction so so like some people would
consider him a zombie that has tur a
zombie lord to someone who is come back
to life and is now helping people awaken
from this zombie-ness there's an article
that dailydot wrote about what happened
here and it was just like it's crazy how
they just don't watch the show they
don't care to get the facts straight but
one of the things they point out is that
in the clip i highlighted a documentary
i did on ferguson and the you know what
the black community was going through
with going on tour and racism and they
said but tim poole failed to mention
that he made that before his politics
did a 180.
so let's assess that real quick
if i literally pull up a documentary i
made seven years ago and say i
completely agree with this message for
the documentary that i put together
seven years ago how have my politics
changed if i'm literally like this
exemplifies my view on on systemic
racism
quite literally it's the same political
opinion as when the documentary was made
and i'll tell you this too
they wanted me to say a line in that
documentary i did not say they wanted me
the final line of the documentary was
that the police of saint louis are that
are are uh were created by in the
descendants of slave catch slave catcher
patrols
and i was like that's a little too much
guys and it's it's not necessarily
untrue in some contexts but it's it for
the mo it's mostly not true there are
some police departments where they
started as you know slave catching and
then most police departments and i
looked all this up we they were just
ideas and institutions that were adopted
from i think france and other european
countries that we decided to implement
here as we expanded sheriff's department
and law enforcement
so i'm like that goes too far that's
what they wanted in it
so my politics haven't changed on this
but it's really interesting because what
that means is this group of people
revolt like they they they moved around
me
so here i am in this position on the
left and the establishment media moves
to the left where i stay in the same
position and now they're like look he
spawned a 180. and i'm like yo it's you
guys who wrapped all the way around the
other direction
how is it that i'm gonna defend this and
you're gonna claim i disagree with it
they move so far left that you look far
right
and i haven't gone i haven't moved
anywhere i'm always just lying hey it's
wrong to be racist yeah like i i don't
know what you know i have to i gotta say
this is why i'm really pessimistic at
the end of the member segment i said i
think racism will never go away right
and it was because of people like r.a it
was because he is a white guy who claims
white people are privileged who thinks
he's justified as a white man to tell
minorities what to do and laugh at them
when when people when people talk about
their problems or experiences of racism
he laughs in their face and i was like
why would that go away it meant so this
is this is a guy who in every respect
you know 100 years ago probably would
have been a white supremacist 100 years
ago this country was overwhelmingly
white supremacists and now today many
many people have adopted the more civil
rights view and have become more
accepting and more understanding and
he's still of the mindset it's not just
him i don't mean to single him out it's
it's the woke that they as the white
savior the privileged race has the right
to determine what minorities should be
doing and i'm like what changed what
about white supremacy has changed these
people are still doing it yeah i think
that's why it's important to be
considerate of your virtues um and and
not just change on every issue based on
your gang affiliation or the level of
political power you're going to gain for
standing on this side or acceptance from
larger society i mean i always
throughout my journalism career always
said okay what are my virtues what what
do i represent what ideas am i going to
go out there to the general public and
to me it was always anti-war freedom
privacy the rights of individuals over
the collective and i always stood on
those virtues but i've been called a
right-wing racist tea bagger by chris
matthews of msnbc sean
i'm not sorry sorry not sean hannity
bill o'reilly said we are change is a is
a jihad loving leftist liberal
organization
and and i got slandered for it but my
position has never changed when
obama was in power i was called a
conservative when bush was in power i
was called
a liberal and and again i don't believe
in any of that gang affiliation your
virtues should matter more luke has one
political position
freedom the government sucks yes
absolutely i'm with you
i'm all for that thank you and abolish
taxes all of them
immediately
i'm in new york where we have new
mandates now for the mask and it's just
like if you if you have kids and you
love your kids
you you hate your government if they try
to get between you and your kids exactly
and they they're trying to wear i mean
they had like five-year-olds running
around outside this summer 90 degree
weather
with the mask on
i'm like you guys are waterboarding
these kids basically what is the option
for new yorkers like what do you leave
leave
them like i can't fight i think most of
them in the city area like it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time